we're pleased to have here for the first
time on this show
as an nfl head coach long time coach of
the ohio state and he left the the uh
the the warm embrace of a television
studio job to
dip his toe in the national football
league waters the head coach of the
jacksonville jaguars urban meyer how are
you coach meyer
rich always good to talk to you man i'm
doing good always good to talk to you
what if i
told you that night of the nfl draft in
chicago where you were on the end of the
set as the the head coach at the ohio
state that
one day you would be the coach of the
jacksonville jaguars coach in trevor
lawrence what would you have said if i
told you that
on that day i looked at nobody looked at
you like you had four heads or five
heads and
we would have i'm sure one talked about
zeke elliott or something
right i mean it is it is crazy
do you uh how have you found it so far
the nfl oh i just love our owner i mean
uh you know the owner
and i love jacksonville you know i
always have and
and i you know had this kind of a dream
when
this conversation started and you know i
obviously if you're starting i don't
want to say we're starting at ground
zero because that's not fair
you know it's that there's some really
good players here there's some great
people here
but we're going to try to build
something really special and
it's impossible without a shotgun it's
you you just can't you know i i
i can't say i'm well versed in the nfl
yet but
i'm pretty well versed in building
things and and uh
what we're trying to build here is going
to be very unique very special and
i just we had a nice announcement today
right what uh he's trying to do for this
city jacksonville i don't know rich have
you spent much time here what a place
you know what a city
these people want to win and we got to
put something really good on that field
yeah i mean i i've i've been to the the
stadium uh i've
well i've kind of done it all i covered
the super bowl there in year two of nfl
network i've
i i i'll be honest i i hit a seven iron
uh
into uh the middle of the field during
halftime of an nfl network jacksonville
jaguars game with jackson deville
i uh i was very the toughest uh
golf shot i've ever hit because there
were human beings there a coach i mean
my gosh
um and i've been to the town and i know
how die hard the fans are there in
in duval county and uh i did see what
you tweeted out today
um for some artist drawings and
renderings of a new facility and then uh
uh you know a hotel that's being built
our four seasons if i
if i i saw that correct so how do you
build a culture
how does one do that i know you've you
know uh you've done ted talks you've
written books you've done all sorts of
stuff but what what what do you what
how do you do it what do you do when you
do something like this well first you
have to uh
i always tell people you when you put
together a culture you got to believe it
it's got to be an objective truth
players and everybody are too smart you
know when you start talking about a
culture
culture drives behavior and when you
tell people something it's got to be
true
and what i mean by truth is ours is i i
really believe effort overcomes mistakes
i really believe that greatness is hard
you have to embrace the grind of
greatness
and i believe love and ownership are the
greatest forms of
uh you know team if you have those three
qualities that's something we've
developed over the years it's been
fairly
well timed tested i think it's time
tested through
just being a human being that those are
the qualities of greatness and
these guys have listened they you know
we're gonna that's all to be determined
that all sounds great
but that is our culture and that's you
know the relentless effort
i didn't say be fearless you know don't
don't worry about making mistakes
because you're gonna make a bunch of
them
the second thing is embrace the the pain
of greatness because it is hard you
don't think it's hard then you've
never experienced greatness and then the
last one you better own this place if
you don't own jacksonville this is not
something
that you really love and owned we'll
help you move on somewhere else because
you don't need to be here
and and why why do this why why would
you
leave a st i mean there's nothing more
um
you win every week when you when you're
talking on television you know like it's
a w
uh and i do remember you know even with
the immense
success that i know firsthand as you
know about what the ohio state was doing
that there were times where you know
you're you're holding your head
it it did not look like things were
going
uh enjoyably so why do what you've done
coach meyer that's uh that's a that's a
question of questions i i've been asked
that a lot
i've been asked by that by some that are
very close to me um
but those who know me really well knew
that i think probably had one more swing
um had some chances maybe to go back to
college but you know that ship was
sailed and
you know i didn't want to do that again
the recruiting and all the time spent
and all this stuff that's going on in
college football that
you know i just i just was so intrigued
by this owner i was intrigued by
jacksonville
and then you you know you just this was
a year one thing about this rich this is
not necessarily jacksonville but um
just studying nfl and thought man if you
could just somehow find a way to win
some games in nfl
and take this culture blueprint that
we've worked on for so hard and
surround yourself with you know players
that buy into it and they want to win
and they want to do it the right way
it just became overwhelmingly i wanted
to do it
and that's where we did it urban meyer
here on the rich eisen show it also
helps to have
somebody who's as remarkably talented as
trevor lawrence
be essentially essentially assured
uh if you so chose to take him uh atop
the draft and and you did
what what have you learned about trevor
that you might not have already known
from seeing him in college and knocking
maybe on his door in college and
and and covering him in college what
have you learned
about him yeah i knew trevor not
personally but i knew him a little bit
we shook hands and said hi view times
obviously i'm very close with coach
sweeney i know clemson very well
you know for my tv days and also
coaching days um
great respect for the program but you
know you just don't know
you don't know until you know and here
he comes we weren't allowed to talk to
him during the
uh process in person we did zoom call a
bunch of zoom calls with them we did a
bunch of phone calls with them
a bunch of research you know there's no
way that the one that the cool thing
about this rich is that
everybody had speculation he was going
to be the number one pick
and so did our owner and i hired two
guys with
really extensive nfl experience in
schottenheimer and double
and we went on a a good four to five
week
deep dive and uh there are some
excellent quarterbacks out there in this
nfl draft you're going to see a bunch of
these guys play for a long time
and we can't make we can't miss this one
so well
in in our very strong opinion obviously
he earned the right to be the number one
pick and since he's been
part of organization he's been an a-plus
his work ethic
his community involvement his humility
in front of the veterans
it's been it's been a lot of fun to
watch this develop and
um what about the uh pre-draft
conversation
certainly in our world maybe as we were
bored waiting for the draft to actually
take place
uh about his comments that uh from his
coach wouldn't need football his high
school coach
doesn't really need football in the end
and in the long run
and potentially his um his lack of
losses
in the world not having a chip on his
shoulder and that
might not suit him for the nfl game i
don't
subscribe to that but i just wanted to
put that general
conversation in front of you coach urban
meyer now that we're clear of this yeah
rich i'll be honest with you when i
first read it i was a little bit like
probably the world like wait wait a
minute
let me read this again and then i did
have a conversation and
and we had a long conversation and he
told me the story that there was it was
hours upon hours of interviews
and interview and with whoever wrote
this story and then it
it wasn't a reflection of what actually
you know there's some certain things
that were said and
he's a i've coached players uh i'd like
to believe
i am too as well that are deep in their
faith
and their faith tells you not to serve
other than one god and that's he that he
lives at
and football is not his god is the world
is the
message he wanted to get out that but
he's as competitive as you can get
he loves the game um there is no
hesitancy on our part um but i i
remember reading that and i
you can imagine my phone blown up and
what in the world's going on here
you know he does he eat breathe and
sleep football and
is he you know can he compete or does he
want to compete
those answers are all those questions
all been answered for the
his body of work since he's been playing
a few more minutes left here with urban
meyer head coach of the jacksonville
jaguars here on the rich eisen show and
you spent time uh in the media
as again we've mentioned in this
conversation so with that as the uh
the setup um i you know not to pat
myself on the back but
i've been talking to you for 10 minutes
i haven't mentioned the name tim tebow
yet i think that's remarkable restraint
don't you think
coach yeah you might be the first very
good okay i mean really i mean i've been
really bursting
since so i said hello um and i know that
uh when we talked on the air on nfl
network on the saturday of the draft
that
uh you had not physically seen him work
out
and that in the subsequent telling of
the story when you were on chris
collinsworth podcast that his subsequent
workout you are not there for so
how did tim get the the opportunity can
you walk me through that did he knock on
your door did you are you in search of
somebody to
uh personify your culture build here
in jacksonville how do why does tim have
this opportunity is essentially
my question i'm on his foundation board
i know tim
we talked i knew he was getting ready to
go play pro baseball and
and he did he mentioned to me that you
know i'm in the best shape of my life
and he
he can tell he is and we had a chat and
i said well
he said could you have a couple guys
look at me and i said well
you know obviously let me think this
thing through um
you know i don't want this to turn into
something that you know if it's
but i i said if it's love it's
confidential i'm not a
yeah i'll let some guys look at you and
i showed up and i left
on purpose you know and i uh our gm was
there our tight end coach and our
offense coordinator were there
and they put them through workout they
came back to me and said my gosh this
guy's in incredible shape
he's a big athlete we're our tight end
room has been struggling
um okay let's and i think it did two
other times they had two other
you know they gave him some things to
work on and then they brought him back
and i said you know what you know they
came to me and said i think we should
uh give him a shot and what's the
percentage of making the team
we don't know this is uncharted waters
this is very going to be very difficult
but he's been doing great he's been
doing great practice he's learning the
offense as you can imagine he's working
as hard as anybody
i see a good camaraderie amongst the
team and tim and
and it's a you know it's been good so
far
so what what um what do you think he can
represent
in this locker room that you want to get
across
to people who might still be wondering
even
in just the first few weeks what your
culture build is all about
in jacksonville well he certainly
certainly lived it he uh is a guy that's
as hard working as tough a human being
has ever been around as competitive
but the cool thing is rich i'm finding a
lot of that around here i find him
there's there's we brought in some guys
like that in free agency
uh you know miles jack josh allen uh
some of the core players we have
uh brandon lindner we have some good
core players and
i know we don't play very well you can
say well they're one in 15 i get that
you know we did not play well i didn't
say that but we have good core
competitive players and i think
you know first of all tim's one of 90
and the thing that i've
i've settled in with now that we have 90
in it
when you go kick the ball off you're a
48 i believe it is
46. and that's that's going to be
this to me is a tryout for a lot of guys
and he falls into that category but
to answer your question he's working his
tail off as you can imagine
well i you know and and i don't need to
tell you as well what a compelling
uh story if you will or figure tim is
and the compelling story and figure that
trevor lawrence is and compelling story
and figure that
you are is there any chance that the
jacksonville jaguars will appear on hard
knocks
this summer on hbo that you'd let us in
on something like that even though you
don't have to what do you think about
that
idea well i got miss amy palsex sitting
right here staring at me
in my office because so i'll let her
handle all those conversations and
you know i you know rich you know me
fairly well at least that's
you know i think most coaches want to go
on a submarine and show up on game day
ready to rock and roll
without distraction but i also
understand and respect the nfl
uh what it stands for the network what
it stands for and i do believe this is
an interesting story here
uh and one of the reasons that i
wouldn't mind the world no knowing is
that
we have some really good players and
some really good people here it's a
great city we have a great honor
well i know that uh we did see you uh in
a spot where we didn't expect to see you
this past week with aew
handing a laptop to chris jericho so
you know i saw that one charlie strong i
i told our
team that charlie strong should get an
emmy for his do you see his
i saw his reaction he filled his hands
we only did one cut on that we only did
one cut that's
how good charlie strong is in acting i
saw that and
that's so uh that wasn't a real one
that's not your real laptop is it
urban really oh i don't know if i'm
allowed to you know i gotta go along
with it yeah
good thing is we have another one yeah
i've also met the owner mr khan i know
he's probably got
more where that one came from um well
that was just fun
that was a blast i'm sure your whole
family must enjoyed watching you
do something like that right out of the
gate that was that was oh yeah they uh
they were all over it
okay and that's not a real play on the
on the grease board behind you right
that was something to throw everybody
off right
right coach i did actually walked in and
i looked and i said wait a minute is
that
you know and then i started reading it
no it was not
all right coach thanks for the time
really appreciate it uh i hope to do
this uh
more often and um and i do hope to see
more of you
and your team very shortly hey i really
appreciate you and i really appreciate i
really watched a lot leading up to uh
the last
month or so you of the 40 yard dash deal
you did oh i really i didn't realize you
do that for charity so
rich you're a good man brother thank you
i appreciate that and hey look uh
maybe uh if you need another tight end a
few years from now i can get into uh
fighting shape you know what i'm saying
i'll have my time if you're gonna go
through a triumph
i won't be there but you can yeah
one thing i'll just give you a spoiler
alert your coaching staff won't talk
about how great of a body
i've got uh that won't be uh that won't
be the note you get back but it'll be
good
have a good day take care of yourself
that's urban meyer everybody hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here